eu des cheminots ça a duré trois jours
ça a commencé vendredi ça s'est terminé
hier même s'il y avait encore quelques
perturbations ce matin en fait les
cheminots à l'appel sur toute la cgt ont
indiqué qu'ils exerçaient leur droit de
retrait c'est à dire que à la suite d'un
accident qui a eu lieu mercredi dans
l'est de la france
ils ont considéré qu'ils étaient en
danger et donc dans ces cas là ils
peuvent cesser le travail sauf qu'il ya
des conditions pour sa qui apparemment
n'avaient pas été respectés et donc
l'heure est aux sanctions écoutez
elisabeth bornes c'est la ministre des
transports à l'été ce matin sur europe 1
je pense que effectivement les
procédures qui existent pour permettre
aux salariés aux cheminots d'exercer
leurs droits dans le respect des usagers
avec notamment des préavis où on peut
prévenir à l'avancé les gens que les
trains ne vont pas circuler n'ont pas
été respectées il ya clairement un
détournement du droit de retrait et donc
en effet ça appelle des sanctions
individuelles pour les agents qui n'ont
pas respecté les procédures alors ça les
sanctions pour être concret et c'est
guillaume pepy le pdg de la sncf qu'ils
expliquent elles seront de 70 à 100
euros de retenues sur salaire pour les
agents de la sncf qui ont été
convaincues d'absence irrégulière ça que
ça s'appelle quand vous n'êtes pas au
travail et que vous n'avez pas donné de
raisons pour ça les internautes du
figaro sont assez favorables à ce type
de sanction c'était la question du jour
hier sur notre site et 85%
il était favorable vous notez au passage
le nombre de votants à ce qui n'est pas
un sondage mais plutôt un vote 84 mille
quatre cent soixante dix
jean-mathieu perna ce que ça vous paraît
de bonne politique de vouloir
sanctionner les cheminots qui ne sont
pas allés travailler pendant trois jours
ça a quand même provoqué beaucoup de
désordre il pâques
près d'un million et demi de personnes
qui ont été gênés c'est ça alors ça
provoquait beaucoup des gens et c'est
vrai que c'est un inconvénient terrible
quand on part en vacances et moi le
premier
cinq ans sont essayés voilà puisque je
suis là voilà grâce à la sncf je suis là
on peut dire voilà moi je trouve que
c'est en fait ce n'est pas une grève
comme les autres celle ci c'est ça qui
est intéressant on peut par rapport au 5
décembre prochain où il y aura une grève
par rapport à la réforme des retraites
là il ya quand même une grève pour une
sécurité qui est qu un moment cet
accident a eu lieu parce qu'il y avait
aussi un conducteur tout seuls n'y avait
pas de contrôleur si les agents de la
sncf sont en grève aujourd'hui étaient
en grève
finalement ce week-end est pour les
départs c'était une grève un peu
particulière donc je trouve que les
sanctionner
c'est un peu fort parce que là on est
vraiment au niveau de la sécurité même
du voyageur c'est pas de la sécurité de
l'emploi des employés sncf c'est
vraiment pour les voyageurs donc tous
que cette sanction est un peu
disproportionné he has been à ce qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
j'en pense que il ya deux choses déjà à
distinguer c'est le droit de retrait et
la grève si on les écoute là je n'étais
pas pour obtenir des améliorations
professionnelle mais c'était pour des
raisons de sécurité donc ils ont fait
valoir leur droit de retrait ce sont
deux choses bien distinctes et on ne
peut pas pénaliser sanctionner des
[Musique]
grévistes on ferait des agents qui
exercent ce droit de retrait une
inspection du travail s'est prononcé je
crois que tu auras d'autres y aura
d'autres décisions
elle a expliqué donc que c'est un droit
de retrait qui ne pouvait pas être
sanctionné le problème en fait c'est que
là se cristallise une espèce de rancoeur
qu'on a tous ou presque en tout cas au
moins 85% des gens qui se sont exprimées
à l'égard de la sncf et qui ressort en
fait dans ces moments là quant à la
sanction
en fait dont les agents se sanctionnent
eux-mêmes parce que parce qu'aujourd'hui
que le motif soit plus ou moins
légitimes pour la population ben on les
suit plus on y suit plus et on
al'impression voilà que ça relève à
chaque fois du duduk à trice et à force
de crier au loup comme ils l'ont fait
quand sahara et pour de bonnes raisons
eh ben ça trouve peu d'écho dans dans
notre société alors effectivement il ya
deux inspecteurs du travail qui ont dit
qu'a priori sera de retrait était légale
c'est pas la vie d'un grand nombre de
juristes est en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que le droit de retrait il
il doit être encadrée et apparemment par
un certain nombre de procédures qui
semble-t-il n'ont pas été respectées
richard bouhet quel est votre avis
d'abord je pense que c'est ni au premier
ministre ni à la ministre des transports
de dire si le droit de retrait a été
respectée ou pas alors ça aussi il ya il
ya des procédures et ya normalement
injuste qui doit statuer sur cette
partie là voir l'inspection du travail
avec un droit d alerte si jamais
l'inspection du travail a besoin de se
positionner donc c'est un là on a plutôt
une intention du gouvernement et de la
direction de la sncf d'aller là dessus
plutôt que une réalité aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de faits qui montrent
clairement qu'il y a eu un abus ou un
contournement comme cela est dit c'est
aujourd'hui des interprétations ce ne
sont pas des faits qui sont avérés on
verra ce que dit un juge à un moment
s'il est sollicité
d'autre part moi je suis assez d'accord
sur l'idée développée par jean mathieu
pernin qui est que c'est un droit de
retrait particulier puisqu'il fait suite
à un moment donné à un accident qui
s'est produit sur en région champagne
ardenne et qui a vu quoi qui a vu à un
moment donné un train dans lequel il n'y
avait qu'une personne avoir un accident
à l'intérieur je crois de nombreuses
personnes on se blesser au final mais 80
personnes dans la rame
et surtout qu'est ce qui s'est passé une
personne qui était le conducteur qui a
eu la présence d'esprit alors que sa
radio qui était placé devant ne pouvait
pas émettre les appels d'urgence qui est
sorti et qui a alerté pour que le train
derrière qui était un train de fret avec
quasiment deux mille tonnes en termes de
poids ne viennent pas percuté le train
on a évité une vraie catastrophe
il y avait qu une personne si cette
personne n'avait pas été en capacité de
faire ce geste
que se serait-il passé aujourd'hui on
sait en train de dire qu'il y avait 80
morts à peu près dans dans cet accident
donc les chaunois et 7 non mais cette
fois les procédures aujourd'hui elles
ont enfin ces deux choses le droit de
retrait on peut pas dire que les
procédures n'ont pas été respectées
il y à un débat pour savoir si c'est un
droit de retrait qui a été contournée ou
pas mais ce n'est pas statué aujourd'hui
par contre sur l'objet même de dire que
et les usagers et les conducteurs les
agents les contrôleurs ont besoin
d'avoir des normes de sécurité sur les
voyages je pense que ça c'est entendable
après sa rentrée et c'est bien le
problème
sacré
vraie pagaille et pour des gens ça a été
des vrai traumatisme parce que vous avez
prévu pour certains des rendez vous
professionnels d'aller rejoindre leur
famille sur un moment de vacances ça
c'est vrai mais ça n'empêche que l'
alerte qui est fait elle n'a pas été
fait pour cause et ça c'est pour moi le
résultat aussi de l'état du dialogue
social aujourd'hui à la sncf qui depuis
des mois et la réforme statutaire la
réforme des retraites
aujourd'hui la personne un agent seul
dans les trains montre qu'il ya une
incapacité à être sur un dialogue social
qui empêche ce type de mouvement et on
arrive toujours à ce type de situation
c'est ce droit d' alerte qui a été qui a
été mis en place
aujourd'hui on discute de savoir est-ce
que c'était une journée trois journées
très bien mais les motivations les
motifs
moi je pense que a opposé les usagers et
les conducteurs et contrôleurs c'est pas
la bonne solution il faudrait mettre un
peu tout le monde ensemble à tous les
intérêts communs dans la sphère alors je
vais donner la parole à patrick peloux
mais comme vous êtes tous les trois
d'accord je vais sortir de mon rôle
d'animateur pour donner un point de vue
aussi après tout pourquoi pas moi je
suis gêné par ce mouvement pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que je peux
comprendre que des gens qui se trouvent
dans le même cas de figure que ce
conducteur 10 mais ça peut être
dangereux mais vous avez des centaines
et des milliers de trains qui roulent
avec avec un conducteurs et des
contrôleurs
or ces gens là aussi se sont mis en
grève alors qu'ils n'étaient pas en
danger et que donc à mon avis le droit
de retrait était abusif et puis le
deuxième argument puis après évidemment
vous direz si vous n'êtes pas d'accord
tu sais que moi ce que je pense c'est
que les cheminots n'attendait qu'une
chose c'est de prendre leur revanche sur
la réforme de leur statut 2018 où il y
avait le 34 jours de grève vous vous
souvenez en plus il est des grèves
perlées des grèves par intermittence
comme ça il y avait la gêne maximum pour
l'impact financier minimum pour les
salariés de la sncf et que donc voilà il
se sont ils ont profité entre guillemets
pardon si le terme vous choque de cet
accident
pour essayer de d'établir un rapport de
force et qu'elle a mon avis il ya eu
détournement de du droit de retrait mais
ça n'est qu'un point de vue et
maintenant on est comme celui de patrick
mille est très intéressant et soutiendra
mais invitée à 3 h 50 le dents pour
faire suite à ce que vous dites est ce
qu est ce que vous avez dit est très
juste à dire qu'en fait ils ont utilisé
ce droit de retrait avec un conducteur
qui a évité une catastrophe c'est voilà
or si vous regardez le problème qu'on a
eu à brétigny qui était une catastrophe
ferroviaire avait plusieurs morts
plusieurs morts c'était bel et bien le
manque d'entretien
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
qu'en fait en effet ça provoque une
énorme pagaille dans pays parce que la
sncf est structurante pour le pays parce
qu'on en a tous besoin
on a besoin des trains etc on vit grâce
à ça et c'est la france investit depuis
plus d'un siècle
des millions de l'argent parce que sa
structure et le paysage etc
l'architecturé tout rebond on a
l'impression que le gouvernement l'a un
peu oublié en fait il a peu oubliée donc
du coup il ya sans arrêt même si l'état
a repris la dette de la sncf
ils ont un petit peu oublier ça et ils
ont oublié que finalement un train qui
roule eh ben ça un des normes de
sécurité à la fois sur les voies à la
fois sur le personnel à bord
alors moi comme vous je prends le train
ça m'agace de voir le prix exorbitant de
ces pour prendre le train et c'est au
dernier moment où c'est les retards
avaient tous donc évidemment comme vous
je gueule
évidemment mais la sncf c'est quand même
un truc hyper important en france et on
n'a pas l'impression
et c'est là où si vous voulez le les
mots du premier ministre et de la
ministre de la transition écologique et
des transports se trompe quand ils
disent bon bah on va sanctionner
en fait ceux qui ont fait qu'on a évité
une catastrophe et qui montre vrai
véritablement que on se trompe pas faire
trop d'économies on entraîne une
insécurité
après il est vrai livre
constaté beaucoup de gens constatent les
contrôleurs on n'en voit plus dans les
trains mais c'est cinquième c'est qu'on
envoie sur les tgv et les ter on n'en
voit plus du tout et donc je pense que
chaque français bien sûr on était embêté
un véritablement par par cette grève
mais peuvent constater aussi que des
contrôles il a plu alors d'ailleurs
c'est d'ailleurs un argument aussi de
ceux qui s'opposaient à droit de retrait
en disant ça fait 30 ans que tous les
ter fonctionne sans contrôleur et qu' il
n'y a pas de problème est que ton que ça
a été malheureux cet accident mais qu'il
n'y a pas de danger systémique alors je
suis au regret de vous dire chers amis
que nos internautes sont plutôt ça c'est
le système informatique à votre main ben
oui mais c'est pas vrai c'est que je
viens d'arriver les chiffres que j'aime
c'est logan est de 59 qui exprime son
ras-le-bol de ce nom service public je
cite nicole qui considèrent que ce sont
déjà des privilégiés et que leur grève à
répétition commence à fatiguer elle ne
prend pas le train mais elle est
solidaire avec les usagers le droitiste
qui au moins annonce la couleur
ils défendent leurs acquis c'est de
bonne guerre et babineau qui estime que
cet accident est un prétexte pour et
pour faire usage du droit de retrait et
que c'est en réalité une grève déguisée
pour dénoncer la réforme des retraites
vous êtes quand même d'accord avec moi
qui a des arrière pensées je suis
contente ils en auront des occasions le
sillage de choses à faire un rêve entre
la réforme de la retraite etc
là je crois qu'ils ont annoncés à partir
de début décembre que son 5 décembre une
grève illimitée encore quelque chose qui
va marquer un peu plus l'écart dans les
sondages mais des occasions il en a
jamais manqué la sncf pour pour faire
grève
là je pense que une fois n'est pas
coutume leurs revendications ne relevait
pas du tout du caprice était vraiment
légitime comme elle l'avait été
précédemment
quand on avait évoqué le sujet de la
suppression des petites gares sauf
qu'elle est masqué par quelque chose de
plus grand par une colère bien plus
importante qui masquent parfois les
véritables enjeux que voilà que ça peut
représenter dans ce que vous évoquez des
réactions des internautes qui sont juste
beaucoup les deux premiers en tout cas
se plaignent plutôt un problème de
système
un problème qui est générale qui est
effectivement quand on est en banlieue
qu'on a besoin
d'avoir un train tous les jours le train
souvent il n'est pas à l'heure ils
arrivent en retard
souvent on a des problèmes de sécurité
tout ça existe c'est vrai mais là on est
sur un cas particulier moi d'ailleurs je
suis très étonné le cas qui s'est passé
en champagne ardenne on l'a très peu
décortiqué dans les médias l'accident
lui l'accident lui-même ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi on a évité une
catastrophe pourquoi d'ailleurs ce
conducteur devrait être un petit peu un
héros du quotidien parce que ce qu'il a
fait et quand même hallucinant remontée
1500 mètres sur les voies sur le ballast
pour aller prévenir pourra les empêcher
qu'il y ait l'accident derrière
s'occuper ensuite des voyageurs enfin
tout ça n'est rien quand on la raconte
mais à vivre c'est quand même quelque
chose d'un peu extraordinaire on
pourrait s'interroger en disant qu'il
avait lui-même été blessé mais
exactement et donc on pourrait
s'interroger sur sa en disant mais c'est
quand même aussi un cas d'école et
partant de cela en disant qu'est ce qui
s'est passé et comment faire en sorte
qu'on réponde à ce type de situation
pour qu'ils ne se reproduisent pas avec
un drame qui avait su complètement
d'accord avec vous pour décortiquer dans
la problématique des catastrophes
la catastrophe de la gare de lyon qui
avait eu lieu en 86 et c'est vraiment je
vais dire ça fait très très mal un
accident de train ici le fret avait été
rentrée dans l'avion mais c'est des
dizaines de morts qu'on aurait pu
inventer
oui bien sûr et bien voila merci d'avoir
expérience point de vue c'est maintenant
aux internautes de se faire le leur et
si vous le voulez bien passer à un autre
sujet les municipales c'est pour le
printemps 2020 et
un certain nombre de voix celle par
exemple de bruno retailleau qui est le
patron des sénateurs les républicains
qui était interviewé dans le jdd d'hier
ou bien xavier bertrand qui lui a quitté
les républicains ou bien aurore bergé
qui est l'une des porte-parole de la
république en marche tous ces
responsables politiques souhaitent
interdire ce qu'ils appellent des listes
communautaire alors soyons précis quand
on parle de liste communautaire on
évoque en général un petit parti qui
s'appelle l'union des démocrates
musulmans français
ce parti s'est présenté à présenter une
liste aux dernières élections
européennes alors ils ont fait 0,13 pour
cent des voir autant dire presque rien